and
[Music]
welcome back to the Jetta Julian podcast
control today I'm I don't know where I
am
well we're on the gingely a podcast
recording live from the moon this
episode of the Julian podcast is brought
to you by Squarespace guys if you're
looking to start your own website
Squarespace is the place for you they
make everything super easy they have
plenty of templates whether you're a
blogger musician photographer or you
need an online store setup Squarespace
is the place for you
amazing customer support right now if
you got head to squarespace.com that's
squ ar e SP AC comm / jena Julian you
get a free trial and with that URL you
can save 10% off your first purchase of
a website or domain also guys quip the
toothbrush of the future if you don't
know equip is it's this new futuristic
ultra slim ultra compact electric
toothbrush that's a fraction of the
price of most electric toothbrushes on
the market go to get quip that's GE t qu
IP comm / Donna Julian and it starts at
just $25 but with that URL you get your
first refill pack for free because it's
any little refill bristles every so
often so you always have the best brush
Thank You sponsors Thank You sponsors
while you're reading that okay first of
all I'm in a food coma super hardcore
we'll talk about that in one second I
want to talk about the thought that I
just had a thought I want to hear your
thought that we haven't had a guest in
this house on the podcast since we moved
here
sure I was like where were the guests it
and I just like while you're reading
that I was just thinking that and then I
thought what if we got them like a
really high high chair and base that up
here and we just sat like this and and
looked at that and the whole time talk
the but honestly there's that option
where they're just floating up there or
or we put a green screen on that wall
and they sit over there but we Photoshop
them right here so they don't think
they're really far away they yeah like
we just make
lunch table and they're just all the way
back there at the lunch table but they
sound like they're right next to us okay
yeah we put we put a mattress like this
like up here on like a riser and they're
laying down you'd like a real mattress
or a photoshopped mattress porque no lay
down okay yeah their heads upside down I
don't think people would open the
ceiling and they're dipping down like
spider-man and we talked to them with
their face up side up and then at the
end we both do a spider-man kiss for
them yeah this sounds like fear factor
why would they want to be on our podcast
it doesn't sound fun I'm sorry anyways
we're in a food coma yeah I read a food
coma I'm in my bathrobe because it's
Sunday so we've been trying to like not
do the podcast like on Sundays because
it's like it's always been really
important to me as an adult to have like
the weekends like send me off you know
any doing yeah well game will stream
we'll hang out and that kind of thing
but like if there's a hard line for me
when it comes to like doing work or like
agreeing to things that require travel
like that's once a few and far between
because I try and really keep weekend's
like special to have like family time
and relax and I just recently really
important for your brain
so today where we are podcasting on
Sunday because we had quite the week
Julian got a massive tattoo there's yeah
we'll go over this week there's a lot
that happened this week but yeah
yeah then we played in the tournament on
Saturday for player unknowns battle
groans we play 16 which was badass
pretty badass I was pretty excited but
we were unable to do it before today but
we did already I've done put on my
bathrobe
we made vegan gluten-free garbage plates
which we have not done since we made
that video for my channel my boyfriend
cooks my favorite meal yeah I was
arguably better this time it was that at
this time because we've refined our
technique but I like I can't move or
think like my face is hot like my body
is hot like I don't know what to do well
listen I like this podcast and I like
the fact that we're doing this right
after we ate that meal because it's
putting us in
so like you know when you eat like a
really really really indulgent cheap
meal or something that's not good for
you but you just like go all out and the
way you feel after where are you just
like a little bit like delirious like
you're kind of just like well it's like
almost like you're a little bit off but
Jenna like we were we were downstairs
just kind of hanging out after we finish
eating and I was like what should be
Popeyes about today because by the way
that's like the hardest part about
having a podcast is like each week us
together coming up with ideas that we
think well and also like we're nearing
are we are we nearing 200 episodes where
we have--we're know about peaches'
[ __ ] out of control peach we're
podcasting on YouTube don't lick your
plate so that's that's why she's in a
food coma - so she's being crazy but
anyway I'm gonna get to my point because
I keep I keep diverting okay that
feeling that you get where you're like a
little bit insane after like we wanted
to capture that for a podcast for you so
we pretty much just ate all that for you
guys
with so much food so you're welcome
thank you know this is a there's
something about that so a garbage plate
for those of you who don't know just in
case
it's an upstate New York cuisine from
where you're from where I grew up and
it's half home fries which is like fried
potatoes half macaroni salad and then
you put two cheese burger patties on top
and then you cover it in like a chili
sauce basically they call it hot sauce
then you cover the entire thing with
ketchup and mustard we put on hot
Italian sausage on ours and then all
that was beyond me and then we mixed it
all up and then you eat it and then you
basically just die and go to heaven
because I can't function now it's like
it's so bad that all that goes onto one
plate cuz like it's any one part of that
meal is just that for you right well in
New York they they you order a plate
it's huge like it's you could never eat
it in one sitting unless you're like you
know a giant man you're like that was
good I could never eat one in one
sitting it's way too much food and they
give you a small little bag full of like
sliced white bread with it like oh not
like white like Wonder
like a loaf of bread sliced up but they
they don't give you like two pieces it's
a bag with it and they give you butter
for that like you it's absolutely insane
the amount of food that they give you
Amerika Amerika Amerika but so we made
that because i have heard that they are
vegan garbage place and people tweet at
me all the time like oh they have vegan
garbage late so now I don't look good or
authentic to me
tbh there's like salad happening in
there it's like not okay I've seen
french fries like it's not okay
but we make I'd say clearly a hot topic
for come on very offended the most
authentic vegan garbage plate that I've
ever seen and there's something about
that like taste of everything together
to me that just like makes me want to
cry like it feels like home you know
what I mean well yeah it's it's tied to
like your childhood and like when you
ate that growing up I only ate it in
high school and later okay your high
school hood your adolescence yeah I
wasn't eating but you you tie those like
smells to memories so tightly yeah well
you feed that to a child if you look
that child have a bad time alright I
guess there's a little weird though
because all the places that end in hots
are the places that sell them so they
say hot what does that even mean was
that means like they're a place that
sells like hamburgers and hot dogs and
hot smeeting hot dogs I don't know they
just made that up
well I mean we call like a hot dog he's
like a hot or illegal white hot mm-hmm
so it probably started out with hot dogs
but I don't know that I'm like white hot
American summer no oh that's wet hot
American summer sorry but it's like a
place that sells hamburger and hot dogs
but they're like you know they make them
really fresh but like we wouldn't go to
those places as much as like maybe if we
were in a rush somebody would take me to
like McDonald's why but that's like
better burgers and like better food
there
do they have garbage plates at
McDonald's and ups in you know but they
didn't have a drive-thru at those places
which is probably why mm-hmm first so
good though like after our baseball
games my dad would take me to like a hot
sore like a Donna Bob's when we get ice
cream we bought pickles and ice cream
will
no cheese Varro reminds me I'm just like
just listening to this story it's giving
me the vibe of a place called Foster's
freeze Foster's freeze I know it's not
have you never been the Fosters freeze
it's a place I I don't know where fun I
love alliteration I don't know what like
regions they're in I know they're in LA
cuz I grew up going to them but it's not
it's like an ice-cream a little mini
like drive-thru but kind of you know
stop and shop diner where it's like you
could get a like a burger and fries and
like a soda or you can go get some ice
cream from hostas reason they have like
the cone with like the you can get like
the chocolate coating the hard coating
on the ice cream on the top of the cone
have you ever had that no their ice
cream was like Bar None the best I ever
had when I was growing up like are you
get a cone of milk I love vanilla I'm a
vanilla ice cream van which unpopular
opinion I think it's better than most
flavors but you'd go and you get a bowl
or cone of vanilla ice cream and then
sometimes you would get it like dipped
in the chocolate and hardens so there's
like a chocolate coating on it dude but
like the ice cream was to die for and it
was but I feel you on the memory thing
like like you would go there with your
friends after school or somewhere you
know somewhere on the weekend yeah I
didn't stop by I didn't really start
eating garbage plate since I was in high
school and like somebody had a car and
we would drive yeah exactly you would go
there I'm like lunch break because I can
be at off-campus pass I feel like it's a
hard thing to eat as an adult like you
know like when you're eating trash food
it gets harder and harder for your body
to be like thank you for that
yeah after high school year body so like
I didn't eat it growing up because my
parents weren't sitting around eating
garbage plates all the time but by the
time I was in high school it's like an
amazing food to go get and just like eat
and cuz you're I don't know seventeen
and your body's like give me whatever
the [ __ ] you want yeah and it was um the
Fosters freeze was right on the corner
near Santa Monica College where that's
where our high school football team
played their games at Santa Monica
College so Friday nights we would go out
to the game who was a home game and
later on or before the game we would
stop by Foster's for you one of those
boys that would go to all the football
games so no I the reason I would go to
football games is because I was like
best friends with a few
players hot so I had a bunch of friends
on the team but I wouldn't really like
generally we wouldn't sit in the stands
like they would let us on the field so
we would kind of be on the sidelines so
you like use special access yeah I had
some good accident I mean cuz like it
was um the baseball coach near the
football coach and a bunch of my friends
on the football team so we just like
kind of weasels our way on and so once
we got on a couple of times we knew how
to get on most I know the only time I
ever sat on the field for the game was
when I just decided I was gonna keep
score for the boys lacrosse team for a
season yeah sometimes we would have to
move the chains and do the like you're
helping out and stuff Wow I was never
the person in high school that would
like go to a lot of football games I
really care yeah I didn't make everyone
like it wasn't like a I had to be there
but most home games I feel like we kind
of went genuinely bored watching them we
were not dude I was so exciting I cuz I
never played football in high school I
don't played baseball and so like I'm
getting to be on the sidelines with the
guys was a lot of fun but anyway yeah we
would we would and we wouldn't spend the
whole game on the field we would like
hang all that friends in the stands and
then maybe go down at the end or
whatever that was like a popular kid
thing in my school til I go to the
football games and stuff and I was
always like mmm thanks and how many
people went to the games was it a big
game a lot I mean compared ibly that's
the one thing that you take away as a
student-athlete like I literally played
three sports every year fall winter
spring there was never anybody at our
games than the amount is the football
like this is what football is like I
know it really makes you feel like [ __ ]
though you're like damn all these people
are here like you y'all want to come to
my [ __ ] bowling match tomorrow
anybody mom I know you gonna be there
girl I love you no I mean I I hear you
like it it's cool to see like all that
support go to a football game but it'd
be nice if it went to other sports too
but it's like that's it's the football
it's the high school Friday night ladies
it's like a it's a thing yeah they did
have night games in the school paid all
that extra money to turn the lights on
but our games had to end promptly at
like [ __ ] 6 p.m. because oh it's
getting dark and I'm like we have more
time like this we're an Extra Innings
let us [ __ ] and play and they're like no
we'll reschedule it for
March 17th and it's like two months from
now I'm literally stealing a base right
now can you kill the lights back on them
between bases no they wouldn't did like
there were we had nice boys in our
school that would sometimes come to our
softball games yeah yeah yeah that's
cool and like we had that too with the
softball team like we would go support
them they were gonna support us yeah
which is fun like it I mean it was
mandatory for us for some of those
baseball games it's like a thing I think
it was I think it was mandatory for the
softball team to come see us too but we
it wasn't mandatory for us that's
[ __ ] what we just went out of the
goodness of our heart yeah but so you're
saying like a softball teams usually
like fifteen or twenty girls but the
baseball teams like forty-five [ __ ]
people so like Tanny you went to their
game yeah no like five there
we just went we never had to we just
went because Memphis that whole but like
the difference between baseball and
softball culture is always just like
mind blowing and the weirdest and the
worst and the most unfair honestly are
we having this talk now no sorry we can
I'm ready for it
my favorite was in college ball so like
NC double-a baseball or softball like
they are welcomed to just dip like all
the time yeah you're an adult you can
have to that cow yeah but it's an NC
double-a banned substance if you're a
softball player yeah so the whole
baseball team is coming in not that we
want to dip but I'm like this is just as
an example yeah but like if anybody got
caught like smoking a cigarette ever
like or somebody saw a picture of
somebody on a softball team like near a
cigarette it's like you have a terrible
talk with your coach about how you can't
do that and now that's you know
inappropriate or whatever but it's like
the boys are like they're literally some
of them just puked because it's the
first time I've ever dipped kopenhagen
the pitcher is out there just like
spitting all over the place though all
of them in the dugout disgusting I think
dip is disgusting and I would love to
know the updated status on if that's
still a rule for womens and CLA sports
but there is no softball player that's
out there in the mountain
just like you got a fat lip in yeah I've
never seen it anyways it seems unfair if
you if you want to destroy your mouth
you should be able to whether you're a
girl or a guy
yeah it's relatively place on the bar
base stuff is really nice yeah anyways
I'm in a [ __ ] food coma and I'm happy
to be here with you you know I used to
think the word coma meant like a
physical type of bed so when someone
said they were like a person was in a
coma I was like I pictured a bed like
the leuco m'ling bed like kind of like a
hospital bed that's what I thought a
physic that's like that's a coma like so
if I was yeah if I saw like a picture of
a hospital bed I'd be like that's a coma
that's what I thought
not that comas are funny but that's what
I thought so if we're in a food coma
it's like that but the sheets on it are
just like have food patterns so it's a
food coma that's really precious really
haha cummin so did that come myself so
this week we mentioned was pretty big
there's one thing that happened this
week that I'm not gonna mention on the
podraces I haven't even like told you
guys yet and I'll tell you soon it's
like a purchase that happened but aside
from that I got this big old tattoo in
my arm a pitbull showed up at our house
we had our first leak in the new house a
whole bunch of [ __ ] went down but I
guess I'll talk about the tattoo for a
second because I think people wanted
here but I did mention in the vlog that
both of my tattoos that I've caught in
the last couple months I'm going to make
an actual video on and it's gonna be not
just as log it's gonna be something that
I've been thinking about and I want to
make it a little more special and a
comprehensive comprehensive but um yeah
I got this 9 hours sitting so where the
wild things are themed half-sleeve it's
so cool done by the wonderful honor
coach Akari
from the Warren tattoo and what's cool
is I found her on reddit actually cuz I
was like I follow the tattoo subreddit
and I was like sorting my top of like
the whole year 2018 and like on the
whole sub red I want hers as like one of
the top and it's this astronaut piece
she did with like the pixelation that
she does
and I was like [ __ ] like that is so cool
I love her color I love her like
abstract look and I was like I'll
probably I'll probably we're gonna look
her up on Instagram she'll have five
million followers or whatever she has
like mm yeah and like could book me in
like a month and I was like holy [ __ ]
what how is she like and you know I got
my first piece I got this one done and
then I got this one and they were kind
of within the same like four or five
months but um I was talking to her
during this piece and she had she's only
been tattooing for two and a half years
and she said that the choice to be a
tattooist came between it came down to
do you want to be an animator or do you
want to be a tattooist at its worst and
she chose tattoo artist because well eh
she was able to find a place to do an
apprenticeship or someone would like let
her tattoo and learn for exchange of
like working for free of the shop for a
year whatever but also like I don't know
man I see it's crazy to think that
someone would come down to that decision
like I'm gonna be an animator when I'm
gonna tattoo people forever
but yeah she's not been tattooing long
but she's very good in my opinion and I
love the work she did and after our five
it was pretty much hell so what that's
good it's just really cool like I'm I'm
proud of you for doing whatever you want
with your body and your arm and your
skin and like it's just so rad like that
one of the things I said to Julian about
this tattoo is like it's so beautiful
like even a little kid could look at
your arm from any direction and be like
that is amazing you know yeah like it's
just it's it's a Julian tattoo
everything about your arm right now is
just like awesome I know thank you and
I'm like having you be excited is great
but like okay if you're facing your arm
out there's a the wild thing there and
then you face an in you got max in this
little boat like a little kid I'd be
like that is the cool man right there
right cool man cool man oh yeah CJ
[ __ ] Slurpee copy damn yeah pretty
wild I don't know how you
I have no desire to ever do that you're
a Virgo yeah I am
it's like it would take me with a higher
life to decide what I want he would
never come to this no you just overthink
about oh no thanks
get stressed out yeah yeah so I did that
and well so yeah the pit bull came by a
little visitor this week she's our
neighbor and I saw comments in there too
of from your video there but sorry our
front yard is completely fenced in but
we've you know when we moved in and
stuff we looked around to make sure that
there are no gaps or anything that the
dogs could run through and there they
walked into our neighbor's yard one time
when you weren't here I like all of a
sudden not the same one as the pit bull
the yeah they walked into another yard
so there's like multiple gaps happening
in this fence in our yard we have to
figure it out but we don't really let
them out front just because they're
sketchy sometimes and can just walk away
if they feel like it but one time I I
was like where the [ __ ] is peach and
marbles Carmen's right next to me like a
good boy and peach of marbles are gone
they were just standing in the
neighbor's yard shits they had gone
through like a little gap in there's
like hey what's up yeah what's up fam um
but so there must be a gap I think over
there and we hear her like a bunch and
she's super cute and she'll go up to the
fence like when our dogs are out there
marbles bark but she's like I saw
comments in there being like she's
probably chained up and like we hear her
like no I think the day like during dog
hours first of all I heard her at night
like the dog's name was literally halo
that man loved her yeah I mean like an
excited baby you know what I mean I
think obviously first of all okay if
you're in the youtube comment section
any time you're gonna see people
criticizing animals the way people
handle their animals the kids that way
people handle their kids the parenting
everything there's always everything's
being judged so it's easy for people to
see a pit bull who's jumping all over us
being like Oh bad dog bad dog
it's not trained idiot or whatever yeah
the dog could probably use a little more
training it says she was young she was a
sweet puppy I know that pit bulls
require like extra firm training I know
that but we got to meet their parents
her parents and they were lovely people
and I'm sure they love their dog very
much and
at the end of the day like that you know
hey listen on our dog at least outside
of that two hours that she wasn't okay
yeah it was fun she literally never get
the image out of my head of me looking
at the front door cuz peach was barking
in the front row and she's just like
looking like she is knocked just like
waiting I was like what Jenna there's a
dog at the front door okay come inside
my collarbone hurts
I don't know can you feel it no it's a
bristle refill for when you have a quip
toothbrush system they send you this Wow
look at this refill package I can't
believe it
wonderful guys quick is the toothbrush
of the future it is a small beautiful
form-factor
futuristic looking electronic toothbrush
sets at the fraction of the price of
most electronic toothbrushes it starts
at just $25 it has guided vibrations to
help you with your brush so you can get
the best brush every time and they send
you refill packs with toothpaste and
these bristle heads that you need to
replace because if you don't replace
them your bristles break down and you're
not getting the best brush so equip make
sure you guys have the best brush every
single time and if you don't believe me
which I would get if you didn't want to
believe me that's fine you have to
believe the network of over 10,000
dental professionals who say quit is
awesome it is the the coolest thing
about it honestly is the way it looks it
looks like it was designed by Apple it's
tiny it's clean it's simple but it's
very functional they're they're
subscription plan refreshes your brush
on a dentist recommended schedule
delivering a new brush head every three
months for just five dollars including
free shipping worldwide it starts just
$25 and if you gotta get equip that's GE
tqu yp.com slash them Julianne right now
you get your first refill pack for free
when you get equip electric toothbrush
that's get quick calm / tone and
Julianne and also Squarespace guys if
you're looking to start your website if
you were a blogger
if you have an online store that you
want to create or you have a store and
you want to migrate it to your own
website or you are an artist then you
want to put your art up or your music up
or whatever Squarespace has everything
okay there's no coding
there's no confusing different scripts
to learn required you and the everyday
person can get on Squarespace and get
what they need exactly down to each
little page and button and feature and
the look of the website there's plenty
of templates to choose from they have 24
hours a day seven days a week
customer support which by far is my
favorite thing about Squarespace if
you're trying to customize any little
piece of your website and you get you
run into a wall you get on the phone
with them and they help you through your
issue and they make it exactly how you
want it's pretty amazing I mean the 24
hours a day it strikes home with me
because we're internet people and
sometimes at 3 a.m. I wish customer
service was around but it's not so
Squarespace makes that happen guys think
it dream it make it with Squarespace go
to squarespace.com slash Jenna and
Julianne or click the link in the
description to save 10% off your first
purchase or website or domain or give it
a free try go for a free trial and see
how you like it not paying anything
Thank You sponsors thank you sponsor
honestly I don't know dude it just
started hurting just started hurting oh
yeah read the sponsor into Marvel's face
oh sorry for bopping comfort him you got
a mop no he's got a hard head No
and he started saying that the other day
when we were cooking and it's like now
one of the most annoying things I've
ever heard
yeah he did that and he goes that's my
impression of someone who just cut
themselves while cooking
do you wanna talk about the tournament
at all we should talk about that right
well you would like if Bobby your
leftist in any illness oh no he likes it
it's cool people look how happy he is
yeah he's staring at you like damn you
bet you wish you were up here right Bob
will you just let me know we were we
played in the regionals of the broadcast
royale pubsey tournament this weekend
and we play 16th we had to place what
was there 36 teams 40 teams there were
40 teams it plays 16th and and uh you
know we needed a place 10 top 10 to
qualify we didn't but I'm proud of how
we played I think if those of you who
have been watching us play pub G over
the the months and years like you've
seen our improvements but also I find
but also just there's something to be
said about getting experienced in
tournament atmospheres and like playing
every day Pub G the games are completely
different than they are and the
competitive atmosphere and so we've been
in a fair amount of tournaments now yeah
and I think it's cool that we held our
own and I do think we played well yeah
but um it was it was exciting we made
top 16 and we didn't make top 10 but if
he had to make top 10 you gotta go to
Seattle play in person in person which
is scary like oh my [ __ ] god
eats play land dude that [ __ ] as a wild
yeah as well the prize pool for that
it's like $300,000 right for the finals
well and if we had made top 10 if you
make top 10 to go to the finals you're
you already been automatically get 1000
Wow per player and they fly you out to
Seattle it's so cool though because I
was watching some of these some of these
different players who are in the
tournament who I've been watching just
because I've seen their names in the
tournament with us so I checked them out
and they're like losing their minds that
they qualify they're like we want to see
how is so cool
that's like so badass I love that about
tournaments like this where anyone can
get in and play hard enough play well
enough to get to the point where they're
getting on a flight that's paid for game
in person for more money like that's
badass man that's life-changing but it
was a lot of fun
yeah we're competitive gamers now we're
pro gamers yeah well pro gaming pro
gamer I say we do better in squads Julie
and I played as a duo it's a duos turn
turn assay but we definitely always do
better in squads cuz we always play
squad yeah we play so many squads if
this was a squad's tournament that would
have been a lot of fun yeah I wish it
was community ball beats Wow hungry no
you're not no way no way I'm hungry I
think I'm gonna go get some food no way
Jerry we ate so much food yeah no I'm
hungry what yeah why are you looking at
me and saying weird [ __ ] like that
I don't know cuz I'm in a food coma I'm
laying down at my brand-new body PT it's
okay I think your giant body's beautiful
her giant body is beautiful she's a
sweetheart yeah so was so was halo and
she came over but it did remind me just
how little our dogs are because that
girl was like in the bit when I watched
your vlog though two of her like she
looks so much smaller she was like she
was beds.this squat little like hundred
pound [ __ ] sausage
she was thick like her legs her but her
arms her back that was just like full of
muscle just jacked but like when she
would jump on you it's not like you know
Mike my brother's dog like Kona like if
Kona jumps on you you're just like oh
that's sweet this was like her entire
mass was like coming towards me like
yeah yeah it's a hundred pound person
yeah it was a lot it was it was like
especially when she would get really
excited and like do the thing where she
comes like t-bones you so like your
weight gets thrown off not like straight
up cuz straight up you can kind of see
it coming but when she t-bones you she's
clearly teething yeah
sited like it's really cute yeah I hope
we get to see her again yeah yeah I
think that'd be nice
well just we'll call those people up now
you have their phone yeah coming out so
funny I love the comments on that video
people were being so funny
they were like hallo sneezes Jenna
Julianne oh it's so funny man I they
that was the first dog that we've had
visit our new house though yeah they're
cool well I thought we weren't gonna get
any since everything's all fenced in but
I was wrong but even though like in the
last house we did have some like come
right to our house but like I feel like
we found the majority of them just like
out in the world yeah like I'll chase
any dog mm-hmm I've only successfully
caught a couple of dogs in my life but
I've chased many dogs many a dog and
also few of them have been pit bulls
that you just chase down and get yeah
I'll get them you're crazy dude you're
wild no you I you where the wild things
I well thank you guys for hanging out
for a chill food coma podcast I just
want to quickly say this weekend after a
lot of weeks and months of
pre-production and meetings and thoughts
and writing were relaunching last-minute
trips has a second season and we're
leaving and I'm excited about it so I
wanted to mention it I'm really proud of
you guys but like I'm gonna miss you
okay I'll be back all right so if you if
you watched any of the first season and
you're looking forward to more we're
leaving on Friday we're doing the dart
throw up Friday morning so stay tuned I
have that fly-ass yellow hair the whole
time yeah
but thank you guys for hanging out we
appreciate you hope you have a wonderful
Monday and a wonderful week we'll see
you on Twitch all week long I hope you
eat something
for cheat meal how do you eat something
good for you if you didn't have it on
Sunday you have it today what tomorrow
or Thursday or Wednesday or Friday you
eat what you want girl guys we're crazy
bye
[Music]
[Music]